[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren bei führte nach 85 köpfe fünf
meinungen sie werden heute nicht nur 55
minuten lang bestens unterhalten sondern
sind nach dieser sendung auch bestens
informiert in wir kommentieren heute
eine bewegte nachrichtenlage den
rücktritt von familienministerin eine
spiegel die ausladung von
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
und verteidigungsministerien christine
lambrecht meine gäste heute abend sind
cdu-politiker bundestagsabgeordneter und
unternehmer thomas heilmann
fdp-politiker und bundestagsabgeordneter
christoph meyer der leiter der bild
parlamentsredaktion den werden sie
kennen einen unserer stammgäste ralf
schuler und last but not least den
geschäftsführer der kampagnen plattform
der republik anstelle dass ich ihn jetzt
wie gewohnt mein aufreger des tages
präsentieren möchten wir heute mit der
nachricht des tages starten der
ukrainische präsident seelands gerhard
ein treffen mit bundespräsident frank
walter steinmeier abgelehnt dieser
wollte nach kiew reisen bescheiden jetzt
live nach kiew zu meinem kollegen bild
epa ronzheimer der uns sagen wird was da
vor sich geht bruder eine these
mitgebracht hat hallo paula
lena für uns die nachricht des tages und
auch gleichzeitig die nachricht die wir
für bild hier exklusiv recherchiert
haben heute ukraine verbot für
frank-walter steinmeier für den
bundespräsidenten und das war echter
krimi heute passiert ist wir haben mit
verschiedenen formaten gesprochen mit
regierungsvertretern die uns alle gesagt
haben nein morgen wollen wir ihn nicht
da haben warum morgen offenbar nein das
ist fakt mittlerweile wollte steinmeier
zusammen mit polens präsident duda und
den drei baltischen staat überhaupt dann
von polen richtung kiel fahren und dann
hat der ukrainische präsident sich
erinnert er hat sich daran erinnert wie
frank walter steinmeier zu russland
stand dass er der mit architekt der
russlandfreundlichen politik war dass er
immer gegen karte sanktionen war und
dass er nicht zuletzt nutzten zwei so
vorangetrieben hat wenigen minuten und
ungefähr 1 30 minuten waren es ungefähr
nach unserer exklusiv nachrichten bei
bild.de jetzt vermeldet haben musste
sich dann steinmeier äußern ist ein
bisschen danach aus als wollte er dass
diese nachricht natürlich nicht
öffentlich wird aber als bild dann
veröffentlicht hat musste er sich äußern
und hab dann zugegeben dass er offenbar
nicht willkommen ist ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen weil wir gibt es da
irgendwie zwei herzen in der brust auf
der einen seite verstehe ich würde mir
seelands geht er schläft jeden tag nur
drei stunden der welt waffen hier haben
der welt nicht dass noch mehr menschen
sterben erinnert sich natürlich daran
was frank walter steinmeier für eine
politik gefahren habe die aus seiner
sicht erst dazu geführt hat also ich
kann menschlich diese ausladung total
verstehen auf der anderen seite frage
ich mich was das politisch strategisch
bedeutet und ob es am ende bedeutet dass
man ja in deutschland leute gegen die
ukraine auf bringt die man eigentlich
nicht aufbringen sollte was feststeht
nena und das ist auch meine these ich
glaube dass diese nachricht die nächsten
stunden und die nächsten tage
deutschland aufhören wird und uns vor
die frage gestellt was haben wir bloß
alles falsch gemacht
ja ich glaube auch dass diese these die
nächsten stunden beherrschen wird ich
bin mit ihr einig das ist eine sehr
schwierige und auch vor allem
zweischneidige these ist ich bin
unverdächtig irgendwie putin das zeug
reden zu wollen ich habe die große
dokumentation über steinmeiers
verfüllung in diesen tagen gerade
aufgeschrieben aber ich bin sehr im
zweifel ob das eine gute geste gewesen
ist die wirkung die ausgehen sollte von
diesem besuch war europa steht vereint
mit der ukraine gegen moskau gegen putin
in diesem krieg jetzt zu sagen okay wir
stehen zwar vereint aber den wollen wir
nicht halte ich für durchaus schwierig
als signal mal abgesehen davon
dass
steinmeier der einzige gewesen ist der
gesagt hat ich hab was falsch gemacht
ich habe richtig was falsch gemacht er
hat im prinzip seine komplette politik
in frage gestellt und gleichzeitig
möchte dann die ukraine aber mit seinem
langjährigen parteifreund olaf scholz
der nie so etwas gesagt hat weiter
waffengeschäfte machen das finde ich
nicht logisch und die kanzlerin zum
beispiel hat auch nie darüber auskunft
gegeben wie herr selensky früher bei den
besuchen sich zur deutschen politik
verhalten hat oftmals sind da
diplomatische lobhudeleien durchaus
üblich der dort der ukrainische
botschafter in deutschland wiederum hat
aus privaten gesprächen erzählt das ist
ein ganz komisches stil der sich langsam
breit macht und ich finde das signal
vereint in diesem krieg gegen putin
hätte europa gut zu gesicht gestanden
fangen wir den ball mal auf toll ich ja
aber ich hoffe du bist noch in der
leitung wie ist der unterschied zwischen
schweiz und ist paul nach dort sonst
nehmen wir die natürliche sehr genau
super party frage würde ich gerne direkt
ein dich spielen genau das was ralf
gerade auf also erklärt hat mit olaf
scholz und steinmeier wie empfindest du
das
also erst einmal muss man sagen
dass diese ausladung nicht offiziell
passiert ist das ist ganz wichtig zu
sagen möglicherweise wollte sie gar
nicht dass das rauskommt und ganz sicher
wollte steinmeier nicht dass das
rauskommt wir haben dort mit
verschiedenen quellen gesprochen ist war
jetzt nicht so dass selensky oder jemand
in seinem umfeld
angerufen hat und gesagt hat 'jetzt
macht da mal was draus sondern das ist
durch lange recherche anstatt das ist
vielleicht wichtig für den hintergrund
zu dieser geschichte zu sagen ich glaube
dass man da emotional reagiert hat dass
man gedacht hat moment mal steinmeier
will jetzt die hierher kommen warum
warum brauchen wir steinmeier denn aus
sicht der ukraine ist steinmeier niemand
der in waffen bringen kann es ist
niemand der ihn sagen kann okay wir
machen jetzt die sanktionen sofort das
wäre stolz also in sachen scholz hat man
keine alternative weil man weiß dass ist
der bundeskanzler gleichzeitig ist es
auch so vilimsky hat
größere probleme mit frank walter
steinmeier und auch größere probleme mit
angela merkel weil er sie halt dafür
verantwortlich macht dass die ukraine
überhaupt erst in diese situation
gekommen ist dass olaf scholz und seine
partei da lange eine rolle gespielt
haben dass blendet man so ein bisschen
aussehen kann vielmehr sagt mein okay
der ist erst seit ein paar monaten stück
kanzler und da hat man keine
alternativen mit denen muss man will man
zusammenarbeiten und andrej melik der
botschafter hatte das ja vor ein paar
tagen bereits angekündigt hinsichtlich
eines besuchs dass man lieber olaf
scholz und auch ein paar minister
hätten überhaupt andrej melik der gehört
natürlich zu dieser debatte dazu der
sehr hat er sich bereits angelegt in den
letzten wochen mit frank walter
steinmeier auf heftigste art muss man
sagen in den sozialen medien also hat
steinmeier kritisiert und hat dann ein
konzert eine einladung ausgeschlagen wo
er sozusagen in einem konzert mit
russischen musikern als gast bei wohnen
sollte und hat dann erneut frank walter
steinmeier heftig angegangen also dieser
konflikt hat durchaus eine geschichte
herr heilmann können sie das verstehen
das verhalten was ja herr steinmeier
entgegen gebracht wird also wenn ich sie
lenski den ich übrigens sehr bewundere
für das was er in diesem jahr einen
krieg für die ukrainische bevölkerung
macht beraten hätte hätte ich ihn anders
beraten der die sache ja wie paul
ronzheimer sagt so rausgekommen ist wer
eigentlich mein ratschlag die sollten
sich dass da mal in kiew noch mal
überlegen sie haben ja gar nicht
offizieller ausgeladen deswegen könnten
sie ihn jetzt auch noch offiziell
einladen ich glaube das wäre geschickter
aber die war es natürlich auch
steinmeiers besuch kann nur ein symbol
sein der besuch von olaf scholz würde
was bringen deswegen wäre aus meiner
sicht die richtige antwort der ampel
regierung
olaf scholz macht das was boris johnson
und so auch schon alle gemacht haben
also durchlaufen hat sich dabei dann
auch fotografieren lassen als zeichen
für die welt der natürlich mit einem
versprechen in der hand dran kommen
gastgeschenken sonst hast ja wenig sinn
das geschenk paar waffen ja ich meine
frau berbalk ich bin kein grüner vw hat
doch eindeutig recht und auch die die
die die aussage von frau lamprecht mit
westlichen waffen können die ukraine
nicht sofort umgehen die mag ja stimmen
aber wer sagt eigentlich dass der krieg
im herbst nicht zu ende ist und er ist
er dann am ende wenn die russen wissen
sie kriegen
westliche waffen und werden daran
ausgebildet und hätten dann im herbst
noch eine bessere antwort die wir
hoffentlich und die ukraine von
hoffentlich gar nicht brauchen aber
ausschließen kann dass wir von heute an
können aber das geht ja jetzt ein
bisschen durcheinander nicht allein
waffenlieferungen da wären wir
sicherlich gleich noch
ausführlicher darüber reden das andere
ist wir reden hier über unser
staatsoberhaupt und da ist genau das
richtige gerade schon gesagt worden ich
glaube dass das der weg wäre dass man
vielleicht hier noch mal zusammenkommt
es wäre eine chance gewesen ja also wir
reden darüber dass wir hier eine einheit
in europa in der westlichen welt mit der
nato als erfolg in den letzten wochen
hier glaube ich gegenüber russland eine
front gegenüber russland aufgebaut haben
und da wäre das eine chance gewesen
gerade die differenzen die da sind das
wurde ja eben auch gesagt dass meine
letzten jahre vielleicht hier fehler
oder sicherlich fehler gemacht hat dass
jene chance auch für eine aussprache
gewesen wäre ich glaube das wäre das
zeichen gewesen was von so einem besuch
hätte ausgehen können und die chance
vergeben wurden
so der theseus lassen die stehen also
ich sehe es politisch strategisch auch
so der besuch hätte mehr gebracht und
der frau bringt jetzt so gesehen
diplomatisch wenig aber ich kann es
emotional sehr gut nachvollziehen also
die spd und frank walter steinmeier
damals als außenminister sind halt eben
keine freunde der ukraine gewesen
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel auch nicht
auch das gehört zur wahrheit dazu man
hat es zu lange mit dem russischen
peaceman irgendwie probiert man isst
lieber zu putin geflogen leben nach
moskau als nach kiew das hat man sich in
der ukraine eben gemerkt und es gibt
einen grund warum boris johnson als
freund der ukraine durch kiew marschiert
und von uns tut es eben keiner so und da
kann man über boris johnson lachen aber
seine werte und seine moral kompass der
stimmte der stimmte bei uns im
kanzleramt und auch im außenministerium
sehr lange nicht die national kann man
das wirklich sehr gut verstehen wenn man
sich das wirklich vor augen führt es war
eine fast schon kumpelhafte nähe
zwischen steinmeier und zb seinem
außenminister kollegen sergej lawrow auf
ihrem lieben sergej dann gibt es szenen
wo sie sich am arm diese hatten das ist
schon schwer erträglich man muss aber
eben auch sagen eine einladung von
steinmeier hätte
die botschaft gehabt hier steht er vor
den folgen vor den scherben seiner
außenpolitik das wäre möglicherweise
auch stark gewesen und hätte die ganze
botschaft eigentlich auch unterstützt
ich würde gerne zum ende von teese noch
eine kurze frage an paul stellen und
zwar die frage wie wird es weitergehen
traum also wie glaubst du entwickeln
sich die dinge wird steinmeier
vielleicht doch noch hinreisen wie wird
sich die lenski haltung verändern wie
sieht das aus für die nächsten wochen
mit blick auf die ukraine und
deutschland und besonders steinmeier
also erstmal würde ich ralf
widersprechen dass bei einem groben
besuch sozusagen mit polen und den drei
balten sich der fokus auf stein 100
außenpolitik gelegt hätte sondern er
hätte sich da so ein bisschen mit rein
geschummelt ja die guten in die gute
gruppe richtung hier vielleicht wir
hätten besser wird und er alleine kommen
wir
hätten das wir hätten das sicherlich
entsprechend kommentiert das stimmt aber
vielleicht ist es gerade aus dem grund
besser wenn man das etwas ausgeruhter in
ein paar wochen war auch immer macht ist
gehört ja auch zur wahrheit dazu da
stellen sich schon mehrfach getroffen
haben zuletzt hier im september oder
oktober glaube ich letzten jahre sind
hier weil sie die kennen sich ja als er
nicht so dass er in den vergangenen
monaten immer gesagt hat man scheinbar
wirklich nicht die hand schütteln
sondern dass es ihm jetzt passiert ich
gehe davon aus dass man sich wieder
zusammen findet man muss auch wieder
zusammenfinden denn deutschland ist eben
unabhängig von der frage ob wir genug
waffen liefern eines der wichtigsten
länder oder das wichtigste land mit in
europa da geht es auch um finanzielle
zuwendung und ganz ganz viel hilfe die
wir der ukraine geben dass davon bei
aller kritik nicht vergessen von daher
glaube ich wird man da wieder zueinander
finden und das muss man und zwar deshalb
weil dieser krieg in der ukraine grausam
bleiben wird und noch grausamer werden
wird als das was wir schon erlebt haben
wir müssen davon ausgehen dass mario
pohl in den nächsten tagen fallen wird
dass wir von zehntausenden toten deutsch
sprechen von weiteren gräueltaten von
denen wir vielleicht nie erfahren werden
weil das dann russisches gebiet ist und
keine unabhängigen journalisten dort
zugang haben und wir müssen davon
ausgehen dass der dom bass also im osten
ein heftiger angriff passieren wird auch
wir hier aus kiel werden sicherlich ende
der woche richtung osten fahren um
gemeinsam mit unseren kollegen von dort
zu berichten herzlich dankbar nicht nur
heute für deine einschätzung sein du
bist jetzt seit zwei monaten ja auch
schon vor ort und berichtet jeden tag
und wir freuen uns wenn wir morgen
wieder dir zu hören können für ein
update
danke ein paul und wir machen jetzt hier
weiter mit es war nicht nur frank walter
steinmeier der die medienlandschaft zum
beben gebracht hat sollen dann auch die
zurückgetreten der familienministerin
alle spiegel ihr habt ihr wechseln
zumindest teilweise in jedem politik
wobei der kanzler von zeitenwende
gesprochen hat und ich bin einfach nicht
sicher ob auch die denkt wende schon
stattgefunden hat da gibt es einmal
tatsächlich die
wahrnehmung dass die welt nicht so
friedlich ist wie wir sie lange gehalten
haben und gleichzeitig abgerüstet haben
wir haben wir gedacht wir sind dann nur
von freunden umgeben nein russland hat
seit langem eine sehr expansive und sehr
aggressive politik betrieben zuletzt in
syrien haben das gesehen china schickt
sich auf eine etwas schnellere und
weniger harte art an die hegemonie in
der welt einzunehmen und macht da ich
auch gar keinen hehl draus also wir
haben hier tatsächlich zu gelernt wohin
wir nicht zu gelernt haben das hat man
bei einem spiegel gesehen eine mehrfach
quotierung die zu einem fatalen ergebnis
geführt hat es musste eine frau sein um
die quote zu erfüllen und es musste eine
frau vom linken flügel der grünen sein
jetzt machen die grünen genau das
gleiche wieder sie suchen nach dem
gleichen muster das einzige was keine
rolle spielt ist die kompetenz da wird
von anton hofreiter
gehandelt bis hin zu ricarda lang der
neuen vorsitzenden die gut zu tun hat
jetzt erst mal im neuen parteivorsitz
anzukommen mit anderen worten die
zeitenwende und die denkt wände müssen
bedeuten die welt ist nicht so wie wir
sie uns wünschen sondern wir müssen
endlich die realität zur kenntnis nehmen
parität ist da draußen keine normale
verteilung der gesellschaft wir können
gesellschaften nicht am reißbrett
schneidern und deshalb ist es auch
unsinn so zu tun als müsste man
quotieren für eine welt die es draußen
gar nicht gibt wir können es ist auch
unsinn zu glauben der verbrenner
verschwindet wenn wir einen beschluss
fassen dass er weg ist sondern es gibt
ein anderes mobilitätskonzept dann
steigen die leute um es ist unsinn
atomkraftwerke abzuschalten wenn wir
keinen anderen haben sondern nur noch
aussteigen aus holzverbrennung möchte
man im augenblick auch geradeaus stand
die denkt am ende muss bedeuten realität
first wünsche zecken
absolut also da kann ich jetzt ja 100
prozent zustimmen das sehe ich genauso
ich glaube wir haben ganz großes problem
das sich ich sag jetzt mal im
politischen berlin ganz viel um sich
selbst dreht und das
innerparteiliche befindlichkeiten da die
große rolle spielen man sieht seine
aktuellen bundeskabinett ganz wunderbar
da haben wir ein paar problemfälle nancy
faeser frau spiegel ist jetzt weg frau
lamprecht haben wir auch noch da wurde
sogar kommen wird da kommen wir dann
auch genug stoff für ganz viele
sendungen habe ich mir sicher aber da
hat man sozusagen innerparteiliche
befindlichkeiten quotierungen gewisse
regionale befindlichkeiten er wäre dann
besser gewesen von den grünen als frau
spiegel das ist eine gute frage ich bin
sicherlich kein fan der grünen ja dass
das ist wirklich gefangen hatte was mit
der quote zu tun wer hätte es denn dann
werden müssen also ich denke man hätte
dann vielleicht jemand aus baden
württemberg hoch schicken müssen der ein
bisschen erfahrung hatte ich meine frau
lamprecht fraktion vor allem vorm
spiegel ist ja auch als landesministerin
hoch gegangen aber die war ja
offensichtlich am ende ihrer amtszeit in
rheinland pfalz schon komplett
überfordert die hatte eigentlich schon
dies war schon knöcheltief im wasser im
wahrsten sinn des wortes und dann den
mut zu machen die nach nach berlin zu
schicken ist ziemlich unverantwortlich
sondern können uns antritt im als
bundesministerin war klar dass sie sich
vor einem untersuchungsausschuss im
rheinland pfalz würde verantworten
müssen und ob die nicht performance
während der flut berichte ich dir noch
eine marge habe einmal ab ganz kurz da
passiert es für diejenigen die
vielleicht noch nicht mitbekommen warum
frau spiele jetzt zurücktreten musste es
ist ein gemisch von verschiedenen
ursachen der letztliche letzte anstoß
war jetzt dass sie einen vierwöchigen
urlaub in der flut zeit angetreten hat
sie hat das gerechtfertigt ihre familie
sei in einer ausnahmesituation gewesen
das konnte man auch wirklich gut
nachvollziehen allerdings andere
familien natürlich auch das ministeramt
stellt besondere anforderungen das kann
man überhaupt nicht bestreiten und sie
hatte in rheine als auch noch zwei
ministerien weil sie laut
geschäftsverteilungsplan dann das
umweltministerium noch mit übernommen
hat und war sichtlich überfordert nun
diesen urlaub zu verschweigen und jetzt
erst einzuräumen ist schwierig und dann
in dieser antwort auf unsere anfrage
auch noch eine weitere lüge und dazu
bringen nämlich sie habe alle
kabinettssitzungen per video verfolgt
und dann das wieder zurücknehmen zu
müssen ist einfach hochgradig
unglücklich um es mal ganz diplomatisch
auszudrücken es ging dann nicht nur hat
marktfrau spiegel ja eine konsequenz
gezogen sie ist zurückgetreten so kann
man darüber diskutieren ob das deutlich
zu spät war ob das auftreten am
wochenende das nochmal befeuert hat
insgesamt sind die fakten ja eben
richtig dargestellt worden und ich
glaube auch das stichwort denkt wende
wenn wir über zeitenwenden reden das
genau richtig aber wir müssen uns ja
auch ein stück weit ehrlich machen also
jede partei hat immer ein stück weit und
regionalproporz hat immer ein stück weit
ein ausgleich von verschiedenen
strömungen dass das bei den grünen auf
die spitze getrieben wird und zwar
dergestalt dass denn also teilweise
doppel quotierung stattfinden das muss
glaube ich jeder wähler jeder
wählerinnen und wähler bewährten ja also
am ende des tages gibt jeder parteien
angebot das angebot das die grünen
gegeben haben ist soweit auch bekannt
und konsequent deswegen wenn jetzt nicht
eine ausgewiesene experten in dem
bereich oder experte in dem bereich und
wie in der grünen-fraktion uns allen
auffällt dann kann ich diese kritik
jetzt will die ämter besetzung die noch
vor ostern stattfinden soll nicht ganz
nachvollziehen jetzt warten erst mal ab
wer da kommt auch der dann ein recht
dass er sich oder diejenige hat ein
recht sich einzuarbeiten wir hatten
früher mal 100 tage das ist jetzt so den
letzten 120 tagen seit dem die ampel in
verantwortung ist so ein bisschen
verschütt gegangen aber ich würde sagen
es gibt eine konsequenz gezogen wurden
das ist nicht nur einer bei den quoten
dass das thema wirklich allein herr
heimat freigegeben ich bleibe und ja ist
ganz klar die frage quotieren wir uns
kaputt
also die die wahrheit ist und daran muss
ich einmal ja leider recht geben und das
kann ja auch für die cdu und auch für
die uns die csu ja nageln die haben den
proporz zwischen oberbayern und
niederbayern und franken und wir haben
natürlich auch im proporz und wenn man
sich die kabinette von merkel anguckt
dann waren die auch alle proporz man
müsse auch das system dass jede partei
ihre minister selbst bestimmt also oder
hat gar keinen einfluss darauf in die
grünen nehmen ich muss sagen ich habe
für den urlaub für frau spiegel ehrlich
gesagt mehr verständnis als sie ich
finde die tatsache dass sie in einer
flut das einzige was sie zu einer
pressemitteilung sagt dass man
campingplatz nutzer ändern muss und
ansonsten hatte dazu nicht zu sagen
stellt dann ihr handy ab das finde ich
eigentlich ehrlich gesagt dass größere
versagen weil ich war als
umweltministerin ist man wenn so eine
flut an kommen ist man irgendwie an deck
als kapitän
heute im zeitalter von videokonferenzen
und weiter wie sie diesen urlaub
ausgestellten
so wie das gelaufen ist weil das am
schluss für die grünen glaube ich
unvermeidlich aber ich habe mehr
verständnis ich glaube sie hat er der
umgang mit der krise ist man meistens
das größere problem als sieht der
eigentliche sachverhalten sie war olivia
ist auch falsch wenn man wegen eines
urlaubes in dem man erreichbar ist und
gerade heute mit modernen medien also
ich fahre auch im urlaub aber ich
arbeite praktisch auch jeden tag zum
ärger meiner familie in urlaub und das
kann man so halten da kann man auch
wirklich was machen hatte sie auch
gelogen über die teilnahme von
wald für politiker immer immer
problematisch so
dass natürlich auch gar nicht
verteidigen ich bin auch nicht als sie
die politik
stellung also ich habe bevor ich bin ja
kein berufspolitiker sondern kommen wir
aus der wirtschaft und habe
kumuliert viele jahrzehnte im
ausgetreten gesehen ich hab ich aus
bundestagsabgeordneten jetzt bin ich
beruflich wollte verteidigen nein das
ist also gerade diese gläserne decke
gibt und dass die quote wahrscheinlich
nicht das optimale ist aber irgendeine
antwort müssen wir darauf schon finden
dass wir in bestimmten bereichen
unterrepräsentiert sind und wir haben so
schön in der richterschaft um ein
positives beispiel über die gezielte
förderung von frauen ist ja heute
hinbekommen dass wir da halbwegs okay
sind in manche berufsfelder sind wir es
nicht und ich persönlich muss sagen also
auch unsere partei unsere union sieht
beim thema frauen nicht so super aus
deswegen würde ich jetzt nicht sagen als
allererste spiel
aber aber das ist ja das ist ja genau
der punkt dass er genau der punkt bei
den grünen sehen wir eine mehrfach sich
in
da verschränken die quote und das
funktioniert ganz offensichtlich in
vielen fällen nicht aber nicht das
vorspiegeln problem der quote ist
sondern frau spiegel hat ein
individuelles problem eines
fehlverhalten dieser flut krise besucher
zeigt doch jetzt man kann keinen mann
nehmen mögen noch so geeignet sein weil
ja das kabinett auch pari pari sich
jetzt ja nicht ist ja nicht der fall
lauterbach wo eine familie näher
minister der grünen sich aufgedrängt hat
man gesagt wieso nimmt man eigentlich
nicht den das war ja nicht das problem
frau rasch und will auch die
regionalproporz sind ja von hübel es ist
ja nicht so dass ein bisschen quote okay
ist und nur die straff quote der grünen
ist mist nein es ist immer mist wenn man
es nicht nach kompetenz macht und ich
habe auch kein verständnis dafür dass
unbedingt irgendein obama drin sein muss
und dann nimmt man jemanden der sich da
mühsamer einarbeiten muss wir haben es
im bundeskabinett an anderer stelle auch
wenn der dritte verteidigungsminister in
folge erst mal die rangabzeichen lernen
muss um sich der einst arbeiten dann
finde ich das einfach für die truppe
entwürdigend sie haben das regelmäßig
azubis an der spitze die auch noch gut
bezahlt dann die geschicke lenken sollen
und das haben eigentlich auch wir bürger
nicht verdient aber ich weiß natürlich
dass das realität ist wir möchten wir
das aber trotzdem nicht zu eigen machen
das war ein super übergang ist der these
von ihnen denn jetzt kommen wir zur frau
lambrecht auch eine aus dem ja aus den
aktuellen ministerium absolut und zwar
sage ich christine lambrecht ist ein
sicherheitsrisiko für deutschland in
europa herrscht krieg und wir haben eine
novizin im verteidigungsministerium eine
frau die die rangabzeichen nicht kann
deren erster öffentlicher auftritt
sozusagen in dem sie sich da beschwert
dass sie jetzt diese ganzen
rangabzeichen lernen müsste die sich im
haus abschottet sowohl von der
militärischen führung als auch von der
beamtenschaft die spd apparatschiks in
den bendler-block rein schleppt die
außenpolitisch eine sehr schlechte
performance macht die öffentlich lügt
was die waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
angeht und die auch sonst komplett
fachfremd ist in sachen bundeswehr kein
gespür hat für die truppe kein interesse
hat an der truppe und eine absolute
notlösung ist diese notlösung können wir
uns aber heute nicht mehr erlauben und
deswegen sage ich jetzt muss man die
chance nutzen wenn man zeitenwende ernst
meint muss frau lamprecht gehen und zwar
sofort na ja also ich bin weit davon
entfernt jetzt kopfnoten zu verteilen
aber wenn wir uns die historie angucken
wer in den letzten jahren in der tat das
verteidigungsministerium geleitet hat
dann ist doch vielleicht erstmal
wohltuend dass dort keine person sitzt
die das als eine art von
durchlauferhitzer für ein nächstes
politisches annimmt das war mit der
cdu-vorsitzenden davor so dass wir mit
frau von der leyen davor so und wenn wir
unsere kraft naja wenn ich wusste dass
sie ihren kommen ist sich aber glaube
ich daran gelegen damals ja alle dass
frau von der leyen andere quasi
karriereschritte geplant hat das ist
dann vielleicht eher an frau merkel
gescheitert das heißt vom prinzip ist es
jetzt so mit frau lamprecht dass dort
eine politikerin die sehr viel erfahrung
hat in verantwortung ist ist es
sicherlich nicht alles optimal in den
ersten monaten gelaufen aber wenn wir
uns die aufgaben die vor uns liegen in
der bundeswehr angucken uns die
beschaffung angucken all das was in den
letzten 10 12 16 jahren versäumt wurde
dann ist es vielleicht ganz gut dass
dort eine politikerin sitzt die
eigentlich nicht mehr rücksicht nehmen
muss auf irgendjemanden und deswegen
glaube ich dass frau lamprecht das thema
lügen würde ich so nicht stehen lassen
dass frau lamprecht durchaus als das ist
aber lange rechteck von mir haben sie
aber es gibt auch der botschafter sagt
das eine ist auf der anderen seite auch
so dass der botschafter auch das eine
oder andere über mein parteivorsitzenden
gesagt hat
wo ich sage da sind wir auch in der
aufgeregten situation aber eben auch
schon bei der frage wie lenski glaube
ich ganz gut ausgefüllt hat deswegen
muss man da ein bisschen die kirche im
dorf lassen es ist da nicht alles gut
gelaufen aber es ist gut wenn dort jetzt
eine verteidigungsministerin sitzt die
in der lage ist gegebenenfalls auch
widerstände die in der obersten führung
in der bundeswehr da sind weil es geht
ja nicht nur um mehr geld was wir für
die bundeswehr bereitstellen müssen
sondern auch die ganze beschaffung alles
andere ist desolat in der bundeswehr und
dass da jemand aufräumen kann der keine
weiteren ambitionen hat das zunächst
erst mal eine gute nachricht dass sie
nicht mehr in der opposition sind sonst
hätten sie glaube ich nicht so freuen
die über vor lambrecht geredet weil es
war schon sehr niedrig angelegt das
niveau an mit dem sie vergleichen frau
kam kam bauer hat in der tat zugegriffen
beiden amt brauchte und bei frau von der
leyen war es auch
eine versetzung der kanzlerin zur
bewährung aber das kann ja eigentlich
der maßstabs ja und dann möchte ich aber
noch was dazu sagen annegret kramp
karrenbauer hat sich voll und ganz auf
die bundeswehr eingelassen ist der
empathisch auf die soldaten zu gegangen
ja wir können uns erinnern als es aus
afghanistan aus kabul diese erfahrung
brauchen wir nicht reden
das ist ich das ist ein großer fehler
und wer hat auch die union
stellt ist es wirklich richtig dass wir
wichtige ämter mit leuten besetzen die
nichts werden wollen also hier muss man
auch mal verteidiger und wollte glaube
ich kanzler wäre das ist auch geworden
und zweitens
was ist eigentlich erfahrung
also ich glaube dass das
verteidigungsministerium zu führen
scheint ja parteiübergreifend ein sehr
schwieriges auszusagen ein sehr
schwieriger ist es doch nicht so
schlecht wenn jemand schon mal mit
ministerin erfahrung hat und nicht als
neuling dahin kommen wir der generäle
hinschicken und zum
verteidigungsminister machen also die
frage ist wo kommt eigentlich dann dann
der als ihrer sicht idealtypische
verteidigungsminister oder ministerin
her das war das eine was ich sagen es
gibt verteidigungsexperten parteien na
ja aber die sind dann also ehrlich
gesagt ich habe ja mal wenn auch nur
landesministerium geführt das ist schon
eine ziemlich komplexe aufgabe ein
kleines haus zu führen ein so groß ist
wie das verteidigungsministerium würde
mich sehr warm anziehen bevor man mir so
eine aufgabe anhören können die
wehrdienst verweigert haben jetzt
langsam mehr und mehr durchwachsen ich
habe hier geleistet das problem kennen
würde auch die dienstgradabzeichen
kriegen können aber ich glaube dass
irgendwas entscheiden sind prädestiniert
ja das ist sie eben nicht das würde ich
jetzt also auch ohne ohne falsche
bescheidenheit erstmal in frage stellen
ich glaube wir sollten wir sind in einem
in einer deutlichen außenpolitischen
lage ich finde wir sollten jetzt nicht
anfangen erstmal personal konsequenzen
dann muss ich wieder jemand neues
einarbeiten also ich finde diese hire
and fire möglichkeit in der wirtschaft
ist es so wenn drei leute hintereinander
auf derselben position nicht erfolgreich
sind dann gilt eine klare management
regel müssen wir die positionen
nachdenken um die rang bedingung
nachdenken weil die eierlegende
wollmilchsau die alles kann
jung jetzt so viel besser wir waren mann
und kann also die also lange rede kurzer
sinn die lange reihe ist länger ich weiß
auch nicht ob man von der leyen kramp
karrenbauer und lambrecht auf die man
die also außer sich alle drei frauen
sind würde ich sagen fans bei der
ähnlichkeit ja ich würde sagen wie es
auch alle gleich beurteilen ist findet
es aber am ende des tages das mir zuviel
schulnoten ich finde vorland recht hat
eine aufgabe man muss sie ihrem mann
dass sie das wahrnimmt ich habe das mit
den 5000 helm das ist ehrlich gesagt das
was ich politisch überhaupt nicht
verstanden habe
dass auch die inhaltliche bewertung die
ich verstehe noch nicht ganz was sie
jetzt mit der geheimhaltung will dass er
gar der transport geheim sein muss ist
klar aber die frage wie viele ich meine
bild tv zeigt jeden tag waffen aus allen
möglichen ländern die da sind dass das
offensichtlich klappt die dahin zu
bringen scheint es gott sei dank so
stehen hinter frau lambrecht ich bin ich
bin oppositionspolitiker ich muss nicht
hinter regierungsmitglieder entstehen
aber ich bin ein bisschen ich finde
diese über
vorwurf ich finde wir sollten jetzt erst
mal als land zusammenstehen das heißt ja
nicht dass wir nicht aufsicht führen als
parlament dass wir nicht kritisieren und
dass ich nicht ratschläge geben aber
immer irgendwie gleich zurücktreten nach
120 tagen sich das hat in richtung spd
sagen darf wenn sie mit der truppe reden
wir hören sie überall der letzte
wirkliche verteidigungsminister peter
struck spd
also ja spd kann auch das ist auch sehr
gut so viele probleme die einigung ab
aber vor da auch keine partei die us
politiker also sofern aber
motorradfahrer das ist auch schon ist
wir müssen jetzt auch mal sachen jetzt
ein motorradfahrer der die
sorgen über das programm zu dem
eigentlichen zurück und das ist ja das
wort sicherheitsrisiko es ist ja es ist
ja eigentlich das was mich als bürgerin
sehr alarmiert und sie sind wirklich
davon überzeugt ist vor allem recht ein
sicherheitsrisiko vor augen da ist ja
also ich das ist überspitzt formuliert
aber ja natürlich zusätzlich nicht
gesagt der punkt ist doch der und also
da möchte ich jetzt mal ein paar punkte
machen erster punkt ist frau lambrecht
hat am wochenende gesagt
abrüstungspolitik ist sozusagen immer
noch ihr ziel in europa ist krieg wer
heute noch von abrüstung spricht und
sich aus alten spd reflexen drohne
sozusagen atomare bewaffnung bei was die
zertifizierung der 35 und so angeht wer
sich da nicht von lösen kann der ist
nicht in der realität angekommen
zweiter punkt
wenn ich höre habe ich in der welt
gelesen glaubt von alexanders
aufgeschrieben dass am tag der invasion
der ukraine frau lamprecht sich hat die
fingernägel machen lassen in der woche
weil sie nicht blutrot vielleicht ich
kann es mir nicht vorstellen ja und
danach in die galerie lafayette luxus
morgen in berlin für die es die es nicht
kennen zum shoppen geht für neue
kostümchen dann hat man den ernster lage
glaube ich nicht erkannt und wenn ich da
sozusagen dann auch noch und ob diese
verzögerung die verschleppung bei den
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine mit
bekomme wenn man merkt herr scholz nimmt
die erst kompetenzen weg dann gibt er
ihr vielleicht wieder welche unter
gleichen na ja da muss ich mich schon
sehr fragen und der generalinspekteur
der bundeswehr
oberster soldat in unserem land hat sich
sehr schlecht zu frau lampe ist übrigens
herr meier ihre ihre kollegin frau
strack zimmermann vorsitzende des
verteidigungsausschusses heute in der
welt auch sie haben die qualifikation
ist und sie fragen der in der welt war
was aber weil ich für die unis ruhen
lassen darauf hat sich wie möchten sie
hat den rückhalt von olaf scholz naja
wenn der rückhalt von olaf scholz ein
befähigt 1 im verteidigungsministerium
zu führen da muss man sehr fragen wir
müssen aber jetzt nicht aus
interviewsituationen heraus
interpretationen vornehmen lassen können
doch erstmal die sachlage ganz nüchtern
analysieren das größte sicherheitsrisiko
was diese koalition vorgefunden hat ist
die bundeswehr die über 16 jahre kaputt
gespart wurde ja die in der situation
ist er hat auch nicht die
gewinnmitteilung
beantragen haben wir wurden immer geld
und wir hatten das eben auch schon
geklärt wir reden darüber dass die
gesamte beschaffung desolat ist da wurde
über kindergärten den kasernen
gesprochen da wurde darüber gesprochen
dass waffensysteme
straßenverkehrs tauglich sein müssen
alle
sondersituationen sonderkonditionen die
beschaffung wahnsinnig verteuert haben
so das heißt also als erstes mal müssen
sie feststellen das sicherheitsrisiko
was sie momentan haben weswegen wir
vielleicht auch nicht die waffen die wir
uns gerne wünschen in der menge in die
ukraine liefern können liegt daran dass
die depots einfach leer sind ja das ist
eine bilanz von 16 jahren gerade rechts
verteilen wo man das geführte regierung
in so das thema drohne was sie eben
angesprochen
wir haben in der letzten
sitzungswoche als ampel die bewaffnete
drohnen beschlossen ja das hat die cdu
nie geschafft an welchen gründen auch
immer ist gescheitert auch das nicht
irgendwie ist das nicht wenn ich zuerst
mal festhalten
am tag der angriffs des angriffs auf die
ukraine gemacht hat das finde ich jetzt
ein bisschen billig ich glaube da müssen
wir auf der ebene müsste man nicht hier
miteinander das amt und was die wache
und jeder kann was die waffenlieferungen
angeht auch dazu vielleicht noch einen
punkt bevor wir jetzt über schwere
waffensysteme reden wir müssen doch
zunächst erst mal alle festhalten dass
glücklicherweise die waffen die in der
ersten phase des krieges geliefert
wurden genau richtig waren wir reden
über panzerbrechende waffen wir reden
über flugabwehr das war genau die
unterstützung die deutschland aber auch
andere länder geleistet haben und diesen
angriff vor kiew gern eine abwehr macht
sie müssen erst mal festhalten bisher
war es richtig und jetzt reden wir jetzt
reden sie bisher hat die regierung
ab jetzt den tresen hält darüber dass
wie ich noch keinen einzigen ich bin
haushaltspolitiker kein kein
verteidigungspolitiker wir reden über
ein szenario in der ost ukraine dass in
den nächsten zwei drei vier wochen hier
eine entscheidende schlacht geschlagen
wird sagen die experten unabhängig davon
wie lange der krieg noch dauert das
heißt sie müssten doch eigentlich jetzt
darüber diskutieren welche waffensysteme
jetzt kurzfristig hier weiter
unterstützung geben können und da habe
ich von noch niemanden gehört dass wir
innerhalb von drei vier wochen schwere
waffensysteme in die ukraine liefern
können unabhängig davon ob für einen
ringtausch machen ob der alte nva sowjet
bestände in die ukraine liefern dafür
westliches gerät dann in die nato
partner starten und darüber müssen wir
reden da müssen wir uns ehrlich machen
was hilft der ukraine jetzt im nächsten
wochen und ich glaube dann soll das trio
darüber können wir zunächst erst mal
diskutieren dass wir mittelfristig
darüber diskutieren müssen was wir ein
weiterer unterstützung geben können und
zwar zusammen mit unseren partnern auch
das hat olaf scholz gesagt ich muss
jetzt nicht die ganze bundeskanzler
verteidigen er redlich bemüht wir
kriegen aber nicht mehr alles komplett
jetzt hier geklärt ich glaube frau
lambrecht sollte im blumenstrauß
schicken anhaben ja so nett wurde hier
noch nie geredet über vor lambrecht und
wir sind eine kurze unterbrechung zurück
also da kann ich dann ein lauter
brauchen und nicht ernst nehmen als
sogenannten experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren bei fällen der 85 köpfen und
meinungen jeder von uns hat ein thema
mitgebracht wird ihn bewegt freut oder
schockiert
[Musik]
so nicht privat buschi hergiswil wetten
das auge ist aber niemand von den
politischen parteien traut sich zu sagen
ja das wollen wir einfach nur freiheit
diese grün-roten der damen führen
hofgraben der debatten über die rettung
des weltklimas und um die füße russen
die ratten das thema ist viel zu wichtig
um es nur der ard zu überlassen lasst
den leuten noch mal den spaß wir sehen
da etwas was eigentlich fatale ist in
der politik bei den journalisten deren
job ist es doch gerade abweichende
meinungen zu finden und sie sollen den
doch auch richtig gut
vielleicht einmal kurz einsatz
doch das sind übliche anorak träger aus
schulen brücken und ich habe meinen
beifahrer bei der sache immer bekommt
wer kümmert sich darum niemand
wiesbaden man muss da ganz klein auch
darüber sprechen dass es einfach nicht
mich richtig wohl ist die aufgabe von
journalismus einfach
die verlautbarung der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen die dem zuschauer
schön dass sie dran geblieben sind und
wir wollen keine zeit verlieren und
geben direkt weiter an ihrer hallmann
die uns auch heute eine these
mitgebracht hat ihn bewegt ja ich glaube
dass und das leider schon länger dass
wir deutschland ganz grundsätzlich
reformieren müssen und wir brauchen
nicht nur ein beschleunigungsgesetz in
einzelnen fällen wie jetzt für den
klimaschutz sondern wir brauchen eine
ganz grundsätzliche neuorientierung
wir sind zu langsam wir haben viel zu
viele auf geteilten zuständigkeiten
zwischen kommunen ländern bund und
europa ist viel zu viel um geklärt
werden keine entscheidungsgremien wenn
wir das nicht endlich hinbekommen wenn
wir viele umbau ziele nicht hinbekommen
namentlich nicht die beschaffung zum
beispiel bei der bundeswehr weil wir das
gerade hatten aber wir haben es auch in
kona gesehen sommers ist in 50 prozent
der gesundheitsämter nach zwei jahren
pandemie immer noch nicht eingeführt
werden
das den klimawandel so nicht bewältigt
bekommen und ich bin eigentlich sehr
traurig dass die ampel zwar dieses ziel
ausgegeben hat sowie die cdu ist
aufgefordert hat nur leider die
maßnahmen weggelassen hat deswegen das
ziel nicht erreichen kann
wären wir schon gerade gefragt werden ob
sie dürfen ja ja sie dürfen sich
natürlich direkt jetzt
und ich kann es kann sie nicht ersparen
das ist ja alles richtig was sie sagen
und ich habe da sehr viele sympathien
für aber auf der anderen seite wer hat
letzten 16 jahre dieses land regiert wer
hat in der korona pandemie letztlich
bundeswehr das andere thema hier oder
wer steht dafür dass dieses land stück
weit an die wand gefahren wurde dass wir
genau gucken müssen wie wir die
zukunftsfähigkeit des landes der
verwaltung im bereich digitalisierung
all den anderen bereichen hinbekommen
das ist die union und deswegen ist es
schön wenn sie jetzt sagen dass dass sie
das auch so sehen das haben sie das gebe
ich ihnen zu letzten jahren auch immer
schon getan aber auf der anderen seite
sind die drei ampel parteien jetzt seit
126 tagen in der verantwortung sie
hatten 16 jahre zeit wir haben einen
krieg wir haben eine pandemie die noch
ausläuft geben sie uns ein bisschen zeit
die vorhaben planung zumindest soweit
auf den weg ich werden dass sie sehen
könnt erkennen können dass wir die
probleme die wir im koalitionsvertrag
angerissen haben auch anfangen denn uns
also 3 kommentare es ist eine gemeinsame
und natürlich auch der union werbe alle
länder und alle kommunen beteiligt sind
ist die fdp hat ja auch im boot sie
recht das heißt wir müssen eine
gesamtstaatlichen aufbruch machen die
union ist aber dann die erste gewesen
wegen der neustadt gruppe zu der gruppe
die gibt die dann auch das zu einem
schwerpunkt gemacht hatten und gesagt
wir müssen alle auf jener union umkehren
so und der zweite ist ich werde mich
natürlich überhaupt nicht voran gerichte
kitas jetzt 120 tagen noch keine
ergebnisse haben das nicht mein punkt
mein punkt ist ein punkt ist dass sie
alle entscheidenden maßnahmen die wir
nur am anfang einer korrektur machen
kann auflösung des ressort prinzips
einführung des digitalen systems ist die
fdp habe ich auch gefordert hat aber
dann sind sie wieder an der spd genauso
wie wir gescheitert alle diese
notwendigen strukturellen veränderungen
sind alle nicht passiert und es gibt
dieses schöne bild im digital ausschuss
von sitzen sie nicht drin wir haben ein
wimmelbild gemacht wenn man ganz ehrlich
ist war schon in der alten koalition
digitalem ein wimmelbild ähnlichkeiten
die ehrliche antwort ist das war auch
schon eine merkel schlimme so und dann
haben wir ein wimmelbild daneben wie es
jetzt ist das ist noch schlimmer so es
ist nicht besser und ich schlimmer
geworden daraufhin hatte
ihnen gesagt das bild sei falsch er
würde ein neues liefern darauf warten
wir jetzt schon seit zwei monaten und
die zuständigkeiten zurück
sie hat nicht mal die schulen die
zuständigkeiten hat die ampel geklärt
ist meine prognose die vier jahre werden
sie es nicht schaffen und das bedeutet
wohl jetzt einen schiedsrichter da rein
weil das dagegen sind es klar dass sie
dafür sind wie toll das ist auch klar
deswegen holen wir jetzt hier meine den
experten rein ralf schuler chef von
unserem parlamentsbüro bild wie
erfolgreich ist die ampel denn jetzt
bislang in den letzten tagen ja gut kurz
nach dem start kann man jetzt schwer
sagen wie der zieleinlauf wird sie haben
ja beide recht also ist über die ziele
über die ziele besteht ja gar kein gar
keinen dissenz glaube ich zwischen fdp
und auch zwischen den weil man da hat er
ein dickes buch herausgegeben neustadt
wo man von seite zu seite immer sagen ja
müsste kommen müsste kommen nur da sind
wir wieder bei der denkt wende in vielen
dieser
blockaden spielen ja verschiedenste
mitbestimmungsrechte der der bürger eine
rolle der verschiedenen kommunen bund
und länder blockieren sich gegenseitig
was hier aufzulösen ist ist eigentlich
so grund legend in unserem in unserer
verfasstheit sie können nicht einfach
hingehen und können einen amt
digitalisieren und da jetzt eine neue
software einfach da sagt die
gewerkschaft ja gut da brauchen wir aber
jetzt erstmal drei wochen lang
schulungen für alle mitarbeiter und wenn
jetzt jemand mit dem bohrer durchgeht
und ein kabel verlegt dann muss vorher
neuer raum plan ist es ist alles
verrechnet und und so von von mit
bestimmungen durchsetzt aus guten
gründen immer nur um gerechtigkeit zu
schaffen und um alles auszutarieren dass
wir einfach blockiert sind und dass
aufzulösen das ist so wahnsinnig schwer
das erste billiger davon höre wenn es
mal anfangen die fdp hat früher immer
geworben für eine steuerreform beide
steuerrecht ist nun ziemlich
kompliziertes deutschland gibt einfach
niedrig und gerecht hat man inzwischen
auf allen herren länder das hätten wir
gerne mit der union 2009 gemacht aber da
war frau merkel nicht dabei sind anderen
wäre bestimmt dabei gewesen er selbst
der vorsitzender vielleicht gibt es ja
noch etwas einfaches wie die mehrheit
steuer vereinheitlichen das können sie
einen finanzminister mal vorschlagen der
weiß ganz genau dass er damit scheitern
wird weil die schnittblumen hersteller
jammern die tageszeitung brauchen sehr
verständlich ihren niedrigen steuersatz
das ist ja klar
wir haben
vertraglich vereinbart
haben wir im koalitionsvertrag ohne
maßnahmen wirklich eigentlich ja gerade
wir werden jetzt die nächsten tagen das
prinzip niemals oder in den nächsten
wochen wenn wir aus der ukraine ein
bisschen eine stabilere lage hoffentlich
bald haben werden uns wieder stärker
auch um die innenpolitik kümmern können
ich bitte da wirklich um verständnis
auch gerade herr wissing was die bahn
momentan leistet im letzten wochen
geleistet hat aus warschau nach berlin
das sind alles themen dass ich auch in
der er bislang gerade darüber zu da wir
sind sie aber auch da haben ja lukas
toleranz ist in den letzten monaten
aufgaben gehabt die uns quasi vom
tagesgeschäft abgehalten haben das ist
ja alles zu gestand mir geht es darum
dass die grundsatzbeschlüsse der ampel
und misst die die fdp auch in ihrem
wahlprogramm gefordert haben alle nicht
um mich nicht beschlossen wurde und dass
sie unter jetzt sind digital ministerium
das werden wir nicht tun aber
petzner montali noch mal rein in die
debatte nachdem wir sie könnten auch gut
pressesprecher werden mein leben ist so
rüber ja man merkt richtig wir sind gut
das ist guter sie so rüber bringt da
sind also optimistische bitte eine
optimistische partei das ist schön aber
natürlich auch ihr fazit brauchen wir
eine modernisierung brauchen wir eine
zeitenwende in der politik ja ich glaube
wir sehen ja jetzt sozusagen nach 16
jahren bundesregierung es gibt jetzt
einen aufbruch der er sozusagen über die
ampel organisiert wird da sind ein paar
verkrustungen man ist auch vielleicht zu
satt gewesen am schluss in der union man
hat die letzten vier jahre vielleicht
auch nicht genutzt für viele reformen es
gibt reformstau in deutschland dazu gibt
es noch eine europäische bürokratie die
ohren top drauf kommt aber ich glaube es
ist ein mentalitätsproblem der deutschen
das ist kein regierungsprogramm es ist
kein sozusagen administratives problem
es ist ein mentalitätsproblem die fdp
hatte mal glaube ich digitalisierung
first bedenken second oder so was hatte
sie nur bedingt
digitalisierung first kommt aber das ist
ja ich will jetzt gar nicht mit dem
finger zeigt es ist ja ein großes
problem ich habe in den niederlanden
studiert und habe da eine
steuererklärung gemacht da habe ich mich
mit meiner digitalen bürger id
eingeloggt habe in eine suchmaske
irgendwas eingegeben paar zahlen und
damit war die erledigt wenn ich hier bei
elster reingehe ist das nicht
bürgerfreundlich ist es auch nicht
digital oder einfacher es ist einfach
nur ein monstrum und da haben wir ganz
viele probleme in deutschland wir
regulieren uns zu tode und ich glaube
man muss diesen es geht die csu hat den
ansatz die fdp hat ihn auch wann in one
out als für jedes neue gesetz eine
andere regulierung rausnehmen und
dergleichen ich glaube an das wird nicht
gehen und wir brauchen in radikalen
ansatz und wir müssen verkrustung in
diesem land massiv aufbrechen sonst sind
wir irgendwann nicht mehr da der schönes
wir bleiben bei der zeit wenn er denn
herr meier hat uns auch eine these im
größten sinne zurzeit wenn du
mitgebracht
und abgesprochen sind wir alle bei der
zeitenwende auch sie haben sie haben
richtig formuliert meine these ist dass
uns die zeitenwende in der außenpolitik
wir hatten gerade darüber gesprochen
auch alle in eine
politische realität in deutschland
zwingt wir können das durch alle
politikfelder durch die in ihren das ist
teilweise hier schon passiert wenn wir
uns die herausforderungen angucken vor
denen wir stehen müssen wir zunächst
erstmal uns ehrlich machen und
festhalten dass der staat nicht
unendlich mittel hat die ressourcen des
staates sind endlich wir haben in der
korona pandemie 350 milliarden euro
schulden aufgenommen wir nehmen jetzt
für die bundeswehr in einem
sondervermögen nochmal 100 milliarden
auf wir versuchen die ökologische und
digitale transformation mit 200
milliarden euro sondervermögen
anzuschieben wir haben eine gang aufs
haus widriger haben eine erkenntnis aus
ko runde haben haben sie davor aufgelöst
[Gelächter]
also entscheiden wir haben in der ganzen
zeit für uns und wir müssen uns ehrlich
machen nicht jetzt in den nächsten
wochen aber den haushaltsberatungen 20
23 dass wir zurückkommen müssen zu
stabilen finanzen zur schuldenbremse
dass der staat ausgaben priorisieren
muss das steht auch im koalitionsvertrag
thron und ich glaube das ist ein stück
weit eine politische realität die alle
akteure auch in der ampel so akzeptieren
müssen und anwenden müssen und wenn wir
uns die inflation in deutschland
angucken wenn du uns angucken was jetzt
die koalition entlastungs paketen 1 und
2 auf den weg gebracht hat dann müssen
wir auch festhalten dass wir
wohlstandsverluste hinnehmen werden
aufgrund der aktuellen situation dass
wir hier nicht alle wohlstandsverluste
als staat auffangen müssen und dann ist
das die these die natürlich hier wieder
glaube ich zu konsens führt dass wir uns
darauf zurückbesinnen müssen was dieses
land stark gemacht hat das ist eine
moderne verwaltung das ist aber vor
allem auch unternehmergeist dass es die
soziale marktwirtschaft wir müssen uns
darauf besinnen dass wir pioniergeist
wieder fördern müssen dass wir wieder in
technik und forschung verstärkt
investieren müssen und wir müssen uns
auch ehrlich machen auch das gehört zur
zeitenwende dazu dass wenn wir uns
unabhängig machen wollen zum beispiel
von russischen gas und russischen öl
stärke auch gucken müssen was wir in
deutschland an ressourcen haben dann
müsste darüber nachdenken was wir
nordsee an gasvorkommen haben was
gegebenenfalls die freundinnen wie lange
noch an ressourcen haben und wir müssen
auch zum beispiel über fracking reden
wenn wir darüber diskutieren dass wir
fracking gas aus den vereinigten staaten
über flüssiggas nach deutschland bringen
denn glaube ich ist es allemal
umweltfreundlicher wenn wir einen teil
auch hier in deutschland produzieren und
so können wir es durch all die
bereiche durchgehen wenn wir uns
landwirtschaft angucken vorrangflächen
für
die jetzt von dem
landwirtschaftsminister zwar für nutzt
ihr futter
freigegeben wurden aber ich glaube das
reicht nicht wenn wir uns auf der
anderen seite angucken was in der
ukraine auch in russland wegfällt das
sind alles themen die jetzt eine
realpolitische wende so hoffen wir es
nach der zeitenwende außenpolitik
bedingungen herr heilmann bedeutet zeit
und wenn wir also eigentlich armut
wohlstandsverluste klingt ja eigentlich
so positiv geladene ich werde also durch
das ist wohlstandsverluste was er sagt
und das müssen wir uns eingestehen aber
sein finanzminister von der fdp hat die
größte rentenerhöhung der letzten zehn
jahre gerade genehmigt die sie wären
wir reden über ehrlich machen wir uns an
drucken was was ihre fraktion in den
haushaltsberatungen alles gefordert hat
an mehrausgaben man aufwüchsen sie wäre
dir hast dann tun sie das angepasst also
wer ist mir ja genau richtig aber sie
wären die ersten gewesen die geschrien
hätten wenn wir was die rentenerhöhung
angeht die ja nun auch letztlich nur in
der statistische ist ein statistisches
nachvollziehen ist hier gekürzt hätten
deswegen sie waren diejenigen die am
lautesten geschrien haben als wir die
energie preissenkungen die wir jetzt
vereinbart haben dass die in einem
bereich nicht auch für rentner gelten
das heißt auch wenn wir uns ehrlich
machen wollen dann müssen sie auch sagen
dass sie momentan in der situation sind
als union nicht sie persönlich das
hatten wir eben schon dass sie versuchen
die letzten 16 jahre so ein bisschen
ungeschehen zu machen und zu sagen
ich habe gesagt wir haben recht wir
müssen jetzt haben sie wieder einhalten
dafür bin ich trotzdem für transparente
und ehrliche haushalte und nicht
besonder versorgen
das wäre einmal hat mich ja einen
kurzfristigen anderes aber ansonsten ist
ein sondervermögen ja eine nette
umschreibung für umgehung der
schuldenbremse aber die reise doch
angeführt
von der linken seite der a4 corona er
sollte selbstverständlich in der korona
zeit ausgegeben werden und dann haben
wir gott sei dann gar nicht ganz
gebraucht und dann war unsere idee da
geht er zurück in haushalt und sie sagen
dass die idee ist doch wir geben geld
später aus wenn die schuldenbremse haben
buchungstrick und das schöne ist ja herr
linden es gibt ja das schöne zitat von
kindern das schon weil sie so einen
trick würde er finde er ganz schmutzig
das hat er doch vor acht wochen gesagt
jetzt macht er ihn selber also
mache ich eher ich finde aber ehrlich
gesagt ich würde das gerne so stehen das
ist ja aber ich würde bitten dass sie
uns beide in drei jahren in der
legislatur würde gern einladen und mir
das spiel wir sehen also nichts davon
eingenommen
ich überlege die ganze zeit wie ich
jetzt privat an so ein sondervermögen
was mich auskömmlich freistellt keine
schufa eintrag macht und nicht schulden
genannt wird das würde ich ganz gern
auch noch mal für die private
lebensführung einführen aber im ernst
was ich jetzt schmerzlich vermisst habe
war irgendwo das wort sparen also der
normale bürger weiß ja wenn er noch mal
irgendwie eine sonder geschichte hat
auto kaputtgefahren haben was misst muss
ich irgendwo anders kürzen das ist jetzt
nicht so richtig stattdessen ist
irgendwie die methode der union ja doch
weitergeführt worden wir versuchen alles
mit geld so weit zuzuschütten damit es
nicht wehtut und das verstehe ich zwar
man wird ja nicht als regierung sprach
gerade habe ich kann sagen dass dies
kein bisschen glück hier und da aber wir
haben die schuldenbremse ist sechs jahre
lang eingehalten wir haben ein bisschen
glück gab es gar nicht
wir haben ein gehalt und wie es ihnen
geschieht aber das kann sich ganz so war
es auch in diesem lande das nicht gibt
haben gesagt wir müssen ab dem jahr 2023
die haushaltsberatungen beginnen jetzt
im sommer dazu die schuldenbremse
einhalten und die nettokreditaufnahme
die wir von der vorgängerregierung
übernommen haben im haushaltsentwurf
jetzt sind fast 100 milliarden euro das
heißt dass wir 90 milliarden euro von
diesem ansatz runter müssen das heißt
dass wir sehr wohl darüber reden müssen
dass in einzelnen etats gespart werden
muss das habe ich gesagt mit
priorisieren und konsolidieren deswegen
glaube ich schon dass wir uns in den
nächsten jahren hier dergestalt ehrlich
machen müssen dass wir nicht mehr in
diesen bahnen bis es quietscht
das waren glaube ich ein stück weit ihr
koalitionspartner auf landesebene der
das formuliert hat aber
da gehört es doch zur ehrlichkeit dazu
können wir die schuldenbremse haben dann
heißt das dass wir die ausgaben linie
damit halten und auf der anderen seite
auch das gilt auch für jeden anderen
haushalt werden die haushalte über eine
einnahme linie konsolidiert werden das
heißt wir müssen wirtschaftswachstum
generieren wir müssen also habe ich auch
im dreikampf mit der schuldenbremse
gegangen ja sondern irgendwie aber die
schulden aber wir werden die
schuldenbremse im nächsten jahr
einhalten ein politiker sagen wir müssen
und wir brauchen ein wenig skeptisch das
heißt nicht wir tun und wir werden aber
ist egal wer sie haben ja jetzt schon
als die steigenden energiepreise waren
dann versucht das ganze irgendwie unten
so abzumildern und gleichzeitig steht ja
auch im koalitionsvertrag dass energie
sukzessive verteuert werden soll um den
lästigen bürger solche marotten wie
autofahren und sowas möglichst zu
verleihen muss ich dabei die armen
verteilen
aber kann man so nicht stehen
die energie soll gewollt verteuert
werden da können sie jetzt unmöglich
hinterher immer hingehen und können das
wieder runter subventionieren damit und
dass ich mir jedoch auch nicht immer
sondern wären darüber dass haben sich
erledigen haben nur wir haben wir haben
jetzt gerade eine verteuerung bei
konsumgütern bei lebensmitteln und so
weiter das wären sie irgendwie auffangen
müssen im unteren bereich des einkommens
und da bin ich sehr gespannt darauf da
wird man irgendetwas streichen müssen
fürchte ich einfach man kann nicht
gleichzeitig beispielsweise in der
landwirtschaft auf ökologische
wirtschaft hat umsteigen die flächen die
felder möglichst weitgehend mit paneelen
zu stellen und gleichzeitig dann glauben
dass die preise aber dass ich gerade
meine these dass wir genau hier in der
tat die zeitenwende auch in die
innenpolitik kriegen und
mithalten werden sonst würden wir uns
natürlich auch die frage an sie welcher
vor herausforderungen stehen in uns
bürgern bevor somit werden die nächsten
jahre das größte ist die inflation
glaube ich das wird jetzt auch noch
länger so bleiben und ich sehe da jetzt
ich meine es ist ja zum teil ezb
getrieben jetzt ist es zum europäischen
zentralbank für die zuschauer das ist
jetzt zum teil corona getrieben jetzt
haben wir schlittern wir in die nächste
krise reihen den richtigen krieg aber
das ist schon eine antwort die die man
da geben muss und ich glaube da wird
auch ideologische
bruchstellen geben zwischen fdp und
grünen zum beispiel und der spd was man
da wo man will man geld geben will wem
nicht wo man was kappen muss und
dergleichen bisher hat die ampel ist
mein eindruck ja
ideologische differenzen mit geld
zugeschüttet
ja man hat sich irgendwie geeinigt hat
er einfach geld rausgeschmissen hat dann
schon gepasst das wird in zukunft ja
nicht so gehen auch dauerhaft und wenn
man das dann erst einmal nicht mit
matthias janz bitte die impfpflicht kann
man nicht durchgeht ist dann kann man
sich ja einiges eigentlich man sich vor
wie handelt man seine empfehlen und dann
wird man da ideologische brüche sehen
und dann wird es auch mal richtig
rummste in der ampel ich meine das ist
jetzt sind äußere faktoren die die
reihen schließen das wird so auf dauer
nicht weitergehen man hat es ja
wunderbar gesehen es gibt ja nicht mal
eine mehrheit es gibt auch keine für die
für die impfpflicht mehrheit für
sozusagen das sondervermögen bundeswehr
die 100 milliarden da wir die fcb die
spd jetzt schon zurück rudern das wird
alles sehr spannend da so dass dass die
spd beim sondervermögen zurückbleibt
glaube ich nicht da wäre momentan die
frage ob die union nachdem sie die
letzten 16 jahre bei der bundeswehr so
gewirtschaftet wie sie gewirtschaftet
hat die verfassungsändernde mehrheit wir
brauchen zwei drittel um das grundgesetz
zu ändern
das war kein vorsitzender alles
formuliert da gewinnt man eher den
eindruck dass die union versucht aus
genau dieser öffentlichen zusagen
rauszukommen wir werden ja sehen dass
werden wir nächsten zwei monaten sehen
ob die union bei dem sondervermögen
zustimmt oder nicht um die bundes wir
hier zu ertüchtigen dass ihnen ein
wichtiger das land oder die eigene
partei das land dann lassen sie uns doch
jetzt mehr in den letzten jahren über
das land sprechen und vor welchen
herausforderungen aber ich werde ich
werde ja immer gefragt was die fdp macht
natürlich genau verdienen also dass die
wichtigste herausforderung ist doch
genau die dass wir feststellen müssen
dieses land hat in den letzten jahren
über seine verhältnisse gelebt seit
corona haben wir ganz ganz viele
schulden aufgenommen wir sehen das in
diesem land ganz ganz viel nicht
funktioniert und das sind die
herausforderungen die wir angehen müssen
und das werden wir nur dadurch schaffen
dass wir auf der einen seite
wirtschaftskraft in diesem land halten
deswegen können wir auch nicht so
kurzfristig und so schnell aus den
fossilen energieträgern aussteigen wie
das vielleicht einige andere wollen und
auf der anderen seite dass wir
unternehmer tun dass wir die grundlagen
müssen dass wir die grundlagen
unserer gesellschaft
erneuern wir haben im wahlprogramm von
neugründung gesprochen das ist das was
jetzt in den nächsten monaten ansteht
dass wir uns darauf zurückbesinnen
zurückziehen und dann auch die
diskussion in der ampel natürlich für
und ich glaube dass es unbedingt
notwendig nach den letzten monaten was
jetzt außenpolitischen auf uns
zugekommen ist klicken kann man sehr
schön bemühens zusage und abgerechnet
wird am schluss abgerechnet wird dann in
dreieinhalb jahren kann man dann sagen
ein bläulich übrigen auch versprochen
noch mal einladen aber dann nicht
nebeneinander setzen ich glaube ich
werde sie auseinander setzen wir noch
weniger
ich fühle mich gut aber die letzte frage
ist es ihre these heimat sie dürfen
damit dann auch die diskussion abrunden
und beenden wenn sie noch ein wunsch
oder zwei wünsche äußern wollen was ihn
jetzt als politiker das wichtigste
anliegen wäre wenn sie heute kanzler
werden und das ist natürlich das
wichtigste anliegen wäre das für die
ukraine so unterstützen dass sie den
krieg gewinnen weil das sozusagen ja für
die ukraine absolut lebenswichtig ist
aber natürlich für den ganzen westen
aber wenn sie jetzt in politische
karriere frage gemeint dann würde ich
mir wünschen dass ihr
verfahrensbeschleunigung machen aber
nicht nur für windräder und solarparks
denn wenn wir die ganze wirtschaft
transformieren das ist geht ja schon für
den elektro sir also für denjenigen der
erneuerbaren strom wasserstoff macht
gc-fans beschleunigung nicht für die
netze gilt es dann so nicht und tesla
dann schon gleich gar nicht wir brauchen
eine verfahrensbeschleunigung für alles
und meine hoffnung wäre dass die
regierung sich dazu wenig jetzt
durchringen denn dafür hätte sie
theoretisch die beschlüsse in einem
koalitionsvertrag und dann werden alle
größere wunder dass wir als partei
ergreifen mal aufmachen und wirklich
diesen staat von grund auf neu aufbauen
weil wir werden so nicht weiterkommen
werden alle unsere ziele nicht sehr
schöne schluss waren und damals sind wir
am ende unserer sendung angekommen ist
stand mit dem wort zeitenwende war
eigentlich alles heute verbunden
unabsichtlich vielen dank an meine gäste
und ich wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen
abend bis morgen abend dann sehen wir
uns wieder cs
[Musik]